are you looking forward or a little bit
dreading that your next year might
already be mapped out with Marvel and
then stranger things and that that's all
you're filming
uh yeah next year is going to be very
tough year for me schedule wise uh we've
already gotten in through a lot of that
um
I mean the thing that is gratifying is
that it is there are two things that I
love
I love both characters very much it will
be my goodbye to Jim Hopper though too
which is a big deal
um
fortunately I feel like I have a long
time to say goodbye because I think
we're going to take a long time shooting
these episodes I know those tougher
brothers are very
specific and I know they want to get
that last season I mean if you look at
season four I have a feeling that season
five may not be as long
but it certainly will be packed to the
brim with good stuff that you love I
mean they really are getting better
better at giving you
that home run that the audiences love
and I think that season five will do
that so much so it'll be and I mean to
get to play hopper one last time
will be
really exciting and I'm gonna pour my
soul into it as hard as I can so in that
way scheduling wise it's going to be
crazy you're right I'm just going to be
shooting that but it's been I mean that
role has been the role of a lifetime in
many ways I do I hope I hope I'll play
things further on that will be even more
known in a way I don't want this to be
my my the thing that people
you know
whatever that means but uh uh well I
know but I know what you mean but I want
to know something is it possible that
you're gonna have to play two
Thunderbolts for two weeks go to
stranger things for a week go back to
Thunderbolts or is it gonna be where
you're just shooting Marvel and then
going to stranger things have you been
talking to my lawyers about what have
you been talking to the first aid
because well they're pissed no no
because I I know I know that Thunderbolt
starts filming early next year or
sometime next year and I know that the
duffers have been writing since August
because they told me so I know the
scripts are you know what I mean I know
how filmmaking works and I know they
build you in the room on the deal I need
you saying look I know how this works
guys this has already been read no
you're right it really is it's going to
have to be a back and forth with me
they're gonna have to sort of share me
uh and so it is kind of like I don't
know exactly how they're working it but
it's a week on week off two weeks on two
weeks off something like that where I
will go back and forth they both are
being shot in Atlanta so oh that's
that's actually amazing you got so
[ __ ] lucky oh my god well that was
yeah that may have also been structured
in a certain way but yes it is uh it is
helpful so I can just literally you know
shoot a scene at stranger things and get
in my car and run over to the mar
Pharmacy issued as seen there maybe yeah
sure but I do have you know what I do
have real problems with teams I have
facial hair uh uh conundrums I really
have to figure that out yeah it's a real
thing that that what's really funny is
people don't don't think about that also
you might want to be bigger for
Thunderbolts but you want to be thinner
for stranger things how do you pull that
off yeah all these things you know
Prosthetics have come a long way in so
many different ways so that's wonderful
and then it is another aspect of
creative limitations that you use to
your advantages you know there's great
scenes in like Rocky where like he's up
there's no close-up at the end of the
movie it's because they didn't have
enough film stock to shoot in so it
becomes an iconic thing and so hopefully
the idea will be because of these
limitations you have to shoot these two
characters back to back you use that as
inspiration I was like what can I do
that'll be really cool for Hopper and
really cool for Alexi that's going to be
able to do these things in tandem
um and I'm gonna try to get real create
we're all going to try to get real
creative about it and come up with
something real cool but it definitely is
a factor you don't have just Blank Slate
creativity you have to think
strategically have you actually read the
Thunderbolt script or been told what the
what this is all going to be yes I've
been told what it's all going to be I
have yet to read a script
but I haven't told I've been told the
the ark
uh are you super happy happy or oh my
God this is gonna be awesome
it's gonna be really good it's gonna be
really and it's it's not what you expect
it incorporates a couple new elements
new
things that we have yet to see
um
uh in the universe which is really cool
we introduce a thing that's super cool
it's vital
um
I'm psyched at Julia Louis-Dreyfus uh uh
character is going to be in a bigger way
explored
and I of course you know one of the
things you'll probably know is that the
me and Florence dynamic
will be in there and explored in a way
that's really cool but
you know all these guys like Sebastian's
character Wyatt's character I just love
this mercenary element in the MCU mcu's
always been sort of elevated in a
certain way Captain America even Iron
Man although he has egos
it's always in it for the right reasons
or ultimately does the right thing and I
like these guys who are a bunch of
losers uh or like a bunch of guys who
can't quite get it right and um
and so far what they've pitched me
just feels really cool
it just feels really cool I mean I wish
I could talk more about it but you know
how it is a year and a half we'll we'll
talk at some junket in 2024. exactly
exactly I'll see you then